انظر إليك عمي كيسي لطيف جدًا ، أنا
أحمر جدًا ، ما حجمه الذي سيحصل عليه هذا يعتمد ،
أليس كذلك
على مقدار حبك له أولاً وقبل كل شيء
تهانينا
وأنا أحب الفيلم تمامًا اعتقدت أنه مخصص للأطفال ولكن
ربما  ما زلت طفلاً لا أعلم أنني
استمتعت به
، فلديك مهنة طويلة جدًا مليئة
بالكوميديا المحبوبة ما جذبك إلى كليفورد أم
قيقة أنني أحب المنتج كث
رًا لدرجة أنني علمت أن
سيكون  تجربة
جميلة وسأكون محاطًا بأشخاص يعرفون
ما كانوا يفعلونه ولكن كان ذلك أيضًا
لأنه كان جزءًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
بالنسبة لي لأنه لم يكن
جزءًا كوميديًا خارجيًا ، أعني أنه يقول بضعة
أشياء مسلية جدًا ولكن
إنه مختلف تمامًا عما ألعبه عادةً
نوعًا ما من الحكمة والهدوء
والسعادة والتفاؤل وغامض بعض الشيء
لأنك تتحدث عن كليفورد ،
يجب أن أسألك هل أنت من محبي الكلاب
نعم أحب الكلاب لكنني أفضل القطط
أعني  هناك بعض الكلاب الفردية التي
أعشقها  إيه لديه
شيء صغير سخيف وهو نصف تشيهواهوا نصف خنزير
ونصف
غضب وأنا أعشقه تمامًا ولكن بشكل عام على
الرغم من أنني أحب الكلاب وأحيانًا
أعتقد أنها جميلة جدًا ، فأنا
أفضل مزاج القطط
، هذا لطيف جدًا جونك  أديت مؤخرًا
في دبي ما يشبه لقاء
معجبيك من الجانب الآخر من
العالم ،
ما كان انطباعك عند وصولك
إلى دبي ، يفاجئني دائمًا
عدد الأشخاص من ثقافات مختلفة تمامًا
مثل ما أفعله لأنني كنت
أفكر دائمًا في الإحساس  كان الفكاهة مختلفًا ،
على سبيل المثال ، أعتقد أن
الأسبان والإيطاليين والفرنسيين لديهم
حس فكاهي مختلف عن
الألمان والهولنديين
والاسكندنافيين ، لكنه يفاجئني بالفعل ،
لكنني أعتقد أن السبب في ذلك هو أن الأشخاص
الذين التقيت
بهم كثيرًا ما كان لديهم  بعض التواصل مع
إنجلترا حتى يكونوا على
دراية بجوانب الثقافة الإنجليزية ،
هل رحبوا بك بالقهوة
والتاريخ
نعم وأنا أحب ذلك ، أنا أحب القهوة على ما أعتقد
القهوة جيدة حقًا ، ما هو
مشروعك القادم ، نعم ، لقد
بدأته في دبي ، في الواقع ، أنا أكتب
مسرحية
تكيف لحياة بريان ،
إنها ليست مسرحية موسيقية ، لا توجد أغانٍ
فيها ، إنها مجرد كوميديا مباشرة مب
ية على حياة بريان ولكن  لقد قمت
بتغييرها قليلاً وآمل
أن نحصل على ذلك في برودواي العام المقبل
ألا نحاول إخفاءه أو
شيء
ما في نيويورك ، ولن يعرف أحد حتى هذه
البيتزا مجرد
هذي كبير لماذا لا  نضعك على الميزان هنا يا
صاح ، سأكتب جاك الثقيل ،
هذا السؤال لك عندما
شاهدت شخصيتك ، لقد كان مرتبطًا للغاية
، لقد ذكرني حقًا
بعمي ، لذا أخبرنا المزيد عن شخصيتك ،
نعم أعني هو
عمه المرح الجوهري أه إنه
غير مسؤول إلى حد ما ، لقد حصل على أه البرية
إنه أه نعم إنه ممتع كثيرًا آه
كشخصية ويذهب في رحلة
اكتشاف الذات وبحلول نهاية
الفيلم ربما يكون أكثر نضجًا بعض الشيء
ولكن  اه اعتقد انه لا يزال قليلا من طفل كبير
في  القلب وأنا أحب لعب شخصيات
مثل
هذا السؤال لك يا داربي عندما
نرى المشهد الذي تقود فيه الشاحنة الكبيرة ،
أريد فقط أن أوضح
لجميع الأطفال أنهم سيشاهدون
هذا الفيلم
الذي لم تفعله حقًا  قيادة الشاحنة
بالتأكيد أخبرنا كيف كان الأمر مثل
تصوير المشهد ،
نعم ، لم أتمكن من قيادة
الشاحنة لسوء الحظ ، لكنني أعتقد أن هذا هو الشيء
المفضل لدي
تقريبًا للتصوير ،
وأنت تعلم أن هذه الطاقة كانت عالية جدًا و
كان شديدًا وإيميليًا ، لقد كان مجرد
اختصار عفوي لم تكن تعرف ما
يجب فعله لقد حاولت التخلص منها ،
كانت كما لو كنت لا أعرف ماذا أفعل ،
علينا فقط قيادة هذه الشاحنة ، ثم
لعبت دورها  كأنك لا
تقود ،
ماذا يمكن أن يكون إذا كان عمي كيسي يستطيع
فعل ذلك ، لقد
بدأت القيادة وكان من الممتع
جدًا تصوير الفيلم لأنني لم أكن
أقود السيارة في الواقع ، فقد تم توصيله بهذه المقطورة
ولكن شاحنة أخرى كانت تسحبها من
خلالها  في الشوارع
وكان هؤلاء الناس يمشون
ويراني في السيارة
حسنًا ، شكرًا يا رفاق ، شكرًا
لكم ، شكرًا لكم ،
هذا الكلب يقتلني
[موسيقى]